(Aplauso)
Gracias.
Muchas gracias.
Tal como la persona que hablo antes que yo, soy una -- virgen en TED, creo --
Es mi primera vez aquí, y no se que decir.
(Aplauso)
Estoy realmente feliz que el Sr. Anderson me haya invitado.
Y estoy también agradecida de que tengo la oportunidad de tocar para todos ustedes.
La pieza que acabo de tocar es de Józef Hofmann.
se llama Caleidoscopio.
Hofmann es un pianista y compositor Polaco de finales del siglo XVIIII,
y es considerado uno de los mas grandes pianistas de todos los tiempos.
Tengo otra pieza que quisiera tocar para ustedes
se llama "Variaciones de Abegg" de Robert Schumann
Un compositor Alemán del siglo Diecinueve.
El Nombre de Abegg -- Abegg es de hecho A-B-E-G-G (por las notas en ingles),
Y es el tema principal de la melodía
Estas letras vienen del apellido de una de las amigas de Schumann
(Risas)
Pero el la escribió para su esposa.
Así que si escuchan cuidadosamente,
deben haber supuestamente 5 variaciones en este tema de Abegg
Fue escrito alrededor de 1834, y aunque es una pieza musical antigua
espero que les guste.
(Aplauso)
Ahora viene la parte que no me gusta.
Como el Sr. Anderson me dijo
que esta sesión se llamada "Sincroniza y Fluye," estuve pensando.
"¿Que se yo que estos genios no sepan?"
Entonces me dije, les hablare acerca de la composición musical,
aunque no se ni por donde empezar.
¿Como es que hago mis composiciones?
Pienso que Yamaha hace, realmente, un muy buen trabajo de enseñarnos como componer.
Lo primero que hago es, crear varias ideas musicales pequeñas --
que puedes improvisar aquí en el piano --
y escojo una de ellas para ser mi tema principal, mi melodía principal,
tal como el Abegg que acaban de escuchar.
Y una vez que escojo mi tema principal, tengo que decidir,
de entre todos los estilos de música ¿Que estilo quiero?
Y este año he compuesto en estilo romántico.
Así que para inspiración escucho a Liszt y Tchaikovsky
y a todos los grandes compositores románticos.
Luego, creo la estructura de toda la pieza completa con mis maestros.
Ellos me ayudan a planear toda la pieza,
y luego la parte difícil es llenarla con ideas musicales,
porque es cuando tienes que pensar.
Y entonces, cuando la pieza toma una forma constante --
consistente, perdón -- una forma consistente,
ahora debes pulir esa pieza, pulir los detalles,
Y después pulir toda la ejecución de la composición.
Otra cosa que disfruto es dibujar --
Dibujar, ustedes saben, como los dibujos del arte Japones del Anime.
Pienso que es la locura entre los adolescentes de nuestros días.
Y cuando me di cuenta,
comprendí que existe un paralelo entre el crear música y el de crear arte,
porque el móvil de esa pequeña idea inicial de tu dibujo,
es tu personaje -- lo primero es decidir a quien quieres dibujar,
o si quieres dibujar un personaje completamente original.
Entonces decides, ¿Como vas a dibujar a ese personaje?
Como, ¿Voy a hacerlo en una hoja de papel?
¿Voy a hacerlo en la computadora?
¿Voy a hacerlo en dos paginas como en las revistas de caricaturas
para un efecto mas grandioso? Supongo.
Y entonces tienes que hacer el bosquejo inicial del personaje,
que es como la estructura de una musical,
y entonces agregas lápiz, pluma y cualquier otro detalle que necesites --
eso es pulir el dibujo.
Otra cosa que el componer música y el dibujar tienen en común
es tu estado mental, porque yo no --
Yo soy una de esas adolescentes que se distraen fácilmente,
así que, si estoy tratando de hacer mi tarea,
y no me siento con ganas de hacerla,
entonces me pongo a dibujar, tu sabes, perder el tiempo.
Y entonces lo que pasa es que, algunas veces, no puedo ni dibujar
ni tampoco puedo componer, y es como si
hay demasiadas cosas en tu cabeza.
Y no te puedes enfocar en lo que debes hacer.
Y luego algunas veces, si logras usar tu tiempo sabiamente y trabajas en ello,
consigues lograr cosas buenas de ahí, pero no viene de manera natural.
Lo que pasa entonces es, como si algo mágico sucediera,
y se vuelve natural eso que te costaba trabajo,
eres capaz de producir cosas bellas instantáneamente,
a eso es a lo que yo le llamo, fluir,
porque es cuando a todo tiene sentido y eres capaz de hacer cualquier cosa.
Te sientes que estas completamente en control
y que puedes hacer lo sea que quieras hacer.
Esta vez no voy a tocar mi propia composición porque,
aunque la termine, es demasiado larga.
En lugar de eso, quisiera intentar algo que se llama improvisación.
Tengo aquí siete tarjetas con notas
cada una con una una nota del alfabeto musical,
y me gustaría que alguien viniera aquí y escogiera cinco.
¿Alguien que quiera venir y escoger cinco?
Entonces puedo formarlas en algún tipo de melodía improvisada.
Wow, un voluntario, yay!
(Aplauso)
Gusto en conocerte.
Goldie Hawn: Gracias. ¿Escojo cinco?
Jennifer Lin: Si, cinco cartas. Escoge las que quieras.
GH: Muy bien. Una. Dos. Tres.
Oh, D y F --- me recuerdan algo. (Calificación baja en sistema N. Americano)
(Risas)
JL: Una mas.
GH: Muy bien E de Entusiasmo.
JL: ¿Podrías por favor leerlas en el orden que las escogiste?
GH: Claro. C, G, B, A, y E.
JL: Muchas gracias
GH: Por Nada. ¿Y que acerca de estas?
JL: No las voy a usar. Gracias
(Aplauso)
Ahora, ella escogió C, G, B, A, E.
Voy a tratar de ponerlas en algún tipo de orden.
Muy bien, esta agradable.
Ahora voy a tomar un momento para pensar,
y tratare de hacer algo de esto.
(Aplausos)
La siguiente pieza que voy a tocar
se llama "El Boogie del Abejorro" de Jack Fina.
(Aplausos)